- Défilé militaire devant
le palais présidentiel
et chants autochtones pour
symboliser sa dive
Taïwan célèbre, chaque année,
la fête nationale
de la République de Chine.
♪ ♪ ♪
Des célébrations q
et menaçant quelques jours
seulement après que Pékin
ait encore une fois répéténtionr
Taïwan avec le continent.
contexte actuel
de vives tensions avec la Chine,
les célébrations ont une fortene
de Taïwan assure qu'il n'y a
aucun compromis possible
quant à la sécurité nationale e.
Dans son discours, elle affirme
que la destruction de la liberïn
serait un grave échec pour
les démocraties du monde.
Un discours axé sur
la résistance et la résilience
qui attise le sentiment
de fierté.
Une forte majorité de Taïwanais
considèrent que l'îleest un Éta.
L'appartenance identitaire
à Taïwan est pl
chez les jeunes générations.entl
parti d'opposition, le KMT,
dans le cadre d'une campagne
électorale à la mairie,
ocratie
et de liberté.et le sentiment de
à Taïwan moins fort.
"Nous avons la même culture
et les mêmes ancêtres que
les Chinois, dit celui-ci.
le but ultime."
Statu quo, indépendance,
réunification, la vaste majorité
que c'est à eux de décider.
ait pas de quoi est
fait l'avenir, dit-il, mais
♪ ♪ ♪
Le président chinoe contraire. t
obtenir un troisième manda
historique la semaine prochaine.
La réunification e